[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul aka the guy who's dealing
with a staph infection like Jared called
cordyceps
so just to clarify you I don't have a
staph infection I'm just doing the worst
pun possible to start the video now
speaking of infections throughout this
video we're going to be going through
the multiple stages of what happens when
the cordyceps take over someone in The
Last of Us Universe this ranges from
things that we saw on outbreak day all
the way up to one of the creatures we
encountered during part two because of
that there will be some spoilers but
I'll give you a heads up on that before
we get into it in case you just want
what's in the show if you enjoy the
video please hit the thumbs up button
and make sure you subscribe for
breakdowns like this every day by the
way thank you for clicking this now
let's get into The Last of Us okay so in
the show and game we learned the initial
cordyceps outbreak happens due to people
ingesting a mutated form of it through
flour and yeast products if enough of
the fungi enters the body they begin to
hijack the brain's motor functions and
they take over the host's body now this
is the first stage in which they become
a runner the cordyceps are actually able
to rewire the brain and fix disabilities
so that one no longer carries them we
saw this in the case of Nana Adler who
was parting like it was 1899 again and
she was able to run after Sarah when she
encountered her in the house now one
thing that you might not have noticed is
something that was brought up on the
podcast in the case of Sam series
creators Neil druckman and Craig
Morrison said that the cordyceps
actually picked some stiffness showing
the ability they have to figure out
faults in the body now Beyond ingesting
the cordyceps the show also has the
infections spreading through bites the
game adds an additional layer to it as
well with spores being something that
can give someone cordyceps now though we
don't really see this in either version
the majority of those who are infected
with the fungi ended up dying shortly
after these hosts would find somewhere
to lay down and die and from there
they'd grown to the wall and start
firing out spores into the area this was
normally in dark and damp areas in the
ground which is why you tend to come
across them in basements and also
people's man caves breeding the spores
in even for just a couple of minutes was
enough to cause infection unless people
had to carry gas masks with them at all
times to navigate these areas now upon
becoming infected the first signs of
someone being taken over comes in the
form of muscle spasms episode 1 also
showed us that depending on where you
were bit it could actually drastically
affect how long things take someone
biting the Lego foot has about 12 to 24
hours whereas those bitten in the neck
of face have 5 to 15 minutes this is
purely because the cordyceps need to
travel to the brain so the closer the
bite the easier it is they've never
shown this in the series again but I do
wonder if amputating a leg after a bike
can stop it in its tracks and this is a
tactic that's of course been used in
zombie movies and shows either way the
infection slowly reduces its host down
to their Basic Instincts and not only
will they attack people but they'll also
go after animals too now over the space
of the two days someone will turn into a
runner and at this point they kind of go
into two possible paths the first is
where their body can't really handle it
they're instructed to find a dark corner
and this is where they lay down and die
in the gaming show Sam asks Sally if
people are still in there and I've
always been someone who thought that
they were the wiki says that the
twitching is people trying to fight back
and that sad expression some of them
have when attacking is because they're
genuinely remorseful they don't want to
be doing this but the fungi is
controlling them and thus they're very
much being forced to do horrific things
because of it stronger people will ask
through this though and they'll keep
going being Runners and so on and so
forth though they don't pick up on light
they are alerted by sound and upon
hearing a noise they'll tend to run
towards it if they find a person they'll
end up attacking using their bare hands
and we'll do whatever they can to put
the cordyceps into them the show adds an
additional layer with some being located
in their mouth and it really elevates
the level of horror within them now
though it's never explicitly stated I
think that the infected you find crying
and sobbing away in Corners are the ones
who are probably going to be dead in a
couple of days the ones I keep walking
around will likely become stalkers and
that actually takes us into our next
section the stalkers actually you think
that the stalkers are the scariest form
of them anyone who's played through that
office Block in part two you know what
I'm talking about and the reason that
they're so creepy is because of how they
move now in the case of a runner you
could typically drop down into somewhere
and they wouldn't be aware of you you
could then sneak about and stealthily
kill him whether if he got caught then
you knew what you were dealing with and
that they just run towards you in attack
two things that you were well aware
would happen but stalkers are so
unpredictable as soon as you enter an
area with them they're immediately
alerted but rather than running at you
they'll hide around corners and stalk
you through the level sometimes they'll
run at you and other times they won't
but the fact they're so unpredictable is
what makes them so scary they might all
Ambush you at once or they might just
watch you you really don't know what's
gonna happen which keeps you on edge at
all times with them now during this
stage the cordyceps have study ground of
their face and through their eyes
stalkers usually develop roughly after
two weeks and over the next couple of
years after the fungi grows out the
house face it turns them into a clicker
now these are the infected that I think
the game is most famous for completely
blind the clickers get their nickname
from the fact that they use echolocation
and clicks to scope out their
surroundings possessing increased
strength they're not only able to easily
grapple with their victims but they can
also take more bullets and hits than
your typical infected the fungus on them
acts almost as armor plating and
sometimes you'll have to land multiple
headshots against one to take it down
this can be extremely tense if they're
running towards you and swiping the air
like like I'm not touching you you can't
get mad I'm not touching you I'm in the
game until you lock the shift defense
skill they're one hit kills that only
have to reach you to give you the game
over screen if you know what you're
doing though it's possible to navigate
them pretty simply and you can use
bottles and Bricks to create noises
which will draw them away now we at the
channel we love the clickers and if you
love them too then definitely check out
our last of us Inspired Real fungi
t-shirt it's the best way to support the
channel and it gets you some cool much
as well and the link to the site is in
the description below thank you
thank you now the next stage here from
this is the blower and in the game this
is pretty much a reoccurring boss
character in the series they first
encounter one after escaping Kansas City
whereas in the game you come across it
at the school with Bill when discussing
the creature the creative team said that
this was someone who was really strong
in the real world like a bodybuilder or
a YouTuber now most of these were
infected decades ago and they've kept
going whereas clickers normally turn to
just lie down and die after a while they
were basically Arnie back in the day and
thus they have a resistance to the
cordyceps now because of this resistance
they became huge hulking figures and
they could also throw acidic spores at
you in the game if they grab you they'll
stick their fingers in your face and
tear you apart now this is a similar
fight to what Perry experience in the
show but we can't show it because
[__] YouTube's demonetization
policies anyway the blowers are of
course blind so they can be navigated if
they're not alerted to you and even
though they're extremely powerful it is
possible to beat them now due to them
being heavily covered in fungus they're
also extremely vulnerable to Fire
molotovs and flamethrowers work really
well against them but they do take a
while to kill now for the next part of
the video I'm going to be talking about
the two infected that were introduced in
the second game if you don't want to
know then Cheerio see you later mate buy
a t-shirt while you're on your way out
and I hope to see on our breakdown
coming this Sunday we're still here the
first infected I want to talk about is
the shambler and this shares several
characteristics with the bloater like
them they've been infected for years but
they aren't as large or as powerful as
the bladders are they also attack by
using acidic spores and they're much
more stronger than your typical grunt
death is in the end for them either and
upon being taken out they'll then
explode and spread more acidic spores
into the air now part 2 also has the
most gigantic infected creature that you
come across in the two games when you're
playing a zabby ahead to the wlf
hospital base in order to get medical
supplies for Yara you're unable to get
them on the surface unless you have to
travel deeper into the location in order
to find more this takes you to an area
that was Ground Zero on outbreak day
when things went down no one knew what
was happening and the hospital staff
desperately tried to help out the
infected they went into the basement
which is where they worked away as the
situations started to get worse and
worse and worse got so bad the entire
area had to be quarantined and there
were several sanitary tunnels set up
along with highly secured doors so that
things could get locked down this
obviously didn't stop the infections
from getting worse though and it got to
the point where the military realized
they couldn't handle a situation thus
they locked the doors destroyed the
stairs in and out and never went back
for decades those that were infected
have remained down there and upon
searching the area you come across the
racking this is a creature that was
created by several of the infected
combining into one to make a ginormous
Monster Who's capable of taking
extensive damage the racking is
terrifying and even if you manage to
damage it it will simply have the
infected that a part of it break off and
chase you around the basement eventually
you'll be able to take it down but then
you have to deal with one of the
offshoots and it's a horrifying
encounter and that's people who are
infected on day one so we can pretty
much gather that that is all the stages
however there may be more and if we get
part three then who knows how many
errors in the future that it's gonna
take place potentially if we get a
10-year time Jump Then we're gonna be
about 34 years away from outbreak day
and this could lead to even more
grotesque versions of the infected
anyway that's a video for another time
and now I want to hear which infected is
your favorite well your least favorite
but basically which one of them do you
yourself when you come across in the
game comment below and let me know and
just to let you know we're running a
competition right now and giving away
the 4K Rocky box set to 3 subscribers on
the 15th of March all you have to do to
be on the chance of winning is like the
video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your favorite or least
favorite infected if you beat the
comments are random on the 15th then the
winners of the last one on screen right
now wow save that to you then message me
on Twitter at heavy spoilers if you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out our Last of Us episode 6
breakdown which will be linked on screen
right now it's a bloody long one but
there's so much stuff to talk about and
hopefully I'll see you over there right
after this without the way thanks for
sticking through the video I've been
poor I'll see you next time take care
peace